hoy estudie para el examen de inglés y
aprendí 80 palabras 80 palabras en 10
días ya habrá olvidado cada palabra es
decir que si no me pongo a practicar las
de nuevo voy a olvidar estas 80 palabras
en su totalidad el número de palabras
que recordaré de días después de
estudiar está modelado por y bueno aquí
tenemos la ecuación wv dt es decir el
número de palabras que depende de la
cantidad de días está dada por esta esta
ecuación que tengo aquí de lujo ok es
más deja invitar esto para ti que existe
en el intervalo de 0 a 10 y date cuenta
que es un intervalo cerrado es decir que
incluye el 0 e incluye el 10 y además
tienen toda la lógica del mundo si yo
pongo 10 aquí me va a quedar 0.1 por 10
lo cual es 11 menos 1 es 0 entonces en
10 días ya no recordaré ninguna de estas
palabras y si pongo 0 bueno pues aquí me
quedarían 80 palabras en el primer día
voy a seguir recordando las 80 palabras
cuál es la razón de cambio ok cuál es la
razón de cambio del número de palabras
que recuerdo después de que pasaron dos
días de que estudie para el examen y
bueno aquí la clave es pensar en razón
de cambio pero antes de resolver este
ejercicio te voy a recomendar que pases
el vídeo y lo intente resolver por ti
mismo
muy bien si me piden razón de cambio y
es lo que quiero y además tengo de una
forma explícita la función w de temp
entonces estoy pensando en la derivada
lo que quiero ver es cómo se comporta la
derivada de esta función w de t que
recuerda que es el número de palabras
que recordaré entre días pero esta
derivada la voy a evaluar después que
pasaron dos días que estudie para el
examen es decir la derivada la voy a
evaluar en dos así que primero vamos a
calcular la derivada de esta función w
de temp y quien sea derivada
bueno pues déjame ponerlo así la
derivada la derivada de w de w con
respecto al tiempo ok
quién es esto bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que primero voy a empezar aquí con
este 80 entonces lo voy a poner t el
cual lo voy a poner multiplicando y
después tengo que derivar esta expresión
que tengo aquí ahora date cuenta que
esta expresión que tengo aquí esto de
aquí es una regla de la cadena primero
voy a derivar esta parte de aquí todo
esto lo voy a derivar primero y después
me voy a derivar la parte de adentro
entonces si decimos la parte de afuera
pues el 2 bajan me va a quedar 80 por 2
el 2 baja pongo la función tal cual que
por cierto la función es uno menos 0,1
ok
temp ok y entonces debajo 1 al
paréntesis ok le bajó 1 la potencia 2 -
1 es uno así que no es necesario ponerlo
y después tengo que multiplicar por la
derivada de lo que está dentro la
derivada de esto que está dentro lo cual
bueno la derivada de este cero y la
derivada de éste es menos menos 0,1 de
lujo ahora vamos a tratar de simplificar
un poco esta derivada porque aquí puedo
realizar algunos cálculos fíjate bien lo
primero que creo que te des cuenta es
que tengo 80 x 2 x menos 0,1 lo cual es
menos -16 esto es lo mismo que menos 16
ok déjame escribir que esta es la
derivada la derivada de 2
ok con respecto al tiempo ok
80 x 260 por menos 0.1 es menos 16 ok
esto que a su vez multiplicar esto que a
su vez multiplica a esta expresión de
aquí uno menos 0,1 t ok ahora date
cuenta que esta expresión que tengo aquí
la podría multiplicar por este por este
valor de 16 o también la puedo dejar
justo así y otra cosa que quiero decirte
es que podemos escribir esta derivada de
w con respecto al tiempo de la siguiente
manera esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tener w prima doble un prima de t
ok igual a esta parte de aquí es más
déjame copiarla y pegarla son dos formas
de escribir lo mismo entonces vamos a
escribir las de las dos maneras
distintas que podríamos tenerla ésta o
esta de lujo ahora esta es la razón de
cambio para cualquier día que esté en
este intervalo sin embargo lo que me
preguntan es qué es lo que pasa después
de que pasaron dos días
de que estudie para el examen yo lo que
quiero saber es la razón de cambio
después de que pasaron dos días de que
estudie para el examen por lo tanto lo
que me están preguntando es cuánto vale
déjame cambiada mental cuánto vale w
w prima de té pero para t igualados por
lo tanto voy a sustituir a t por el
valor de 2 ok esto es justo lo que
quiero saber cuánto vale w prima de 2 y
bueno esto es lo mismo que menos 16 a es
más déjame voy a pegar otra vez aquí
esta misma función y lo único que vamos
a hacer es sustituir a t por 2 entonces
déjame quitar el valor de t ok vamos a
quitar el valor de tema y lo voy a
sustituir por el valor de 2 entonces que
tenemos esto y ahora a menos 0.1 lo voy
a multiplicar por 2 x
ok esto por dos y cuantos esto bueno
pues esto es exactamente lo mismo
ok que menos 16 menos 16 que a su vez
multiplica que a su vez multiplica a uno
menos y aquí tengo 0,1 por 2 lo cual es
menos 0.2 ok estoy aquí es menos 0,2 y
uno menos 0.2 bueno pues eso es 0.8 o
0.8 entonces 0,8 de lujo ahora menos 16
por 0.8 bueno pues cuantos esto esto es
lo mismo que y déjame ponerlo justo si
esto es lo mismo que a 8 por 8 el 64 por
2 el 128 128 y recuerdo una vez el punto
va a quedar menos 12,8 12.8 y aquí está
la clave
esto está dado
palabras palabras
sobre sobre día porque estamos tomando
el tiempo en días palabras sobre día
esto quiere decir que la razón de cambio
del número de palabras que recuerdo
después de que pasaron dos días de que
estudie para el examen es de menos 12,8
palabras por día o dicho otra manera eso
quiere decir que después de que pasaron
dos días de que estudie para el examen
voy a estar olvidando 12,8 palabras por
día o dicho de otra manera la función la
curva que tenemos aquí del olvido está
decreciendo con una razón de cambio de
12,8 palabras por día después de que
pasaron dos días de que estudie para el
examen